[Música]
[Aplausos]
o las gracias bueno ya ella lo mencionó
aquí está la famosa mano que todos
conocen este
quiero empezar ya que todos ya saben la
condición
yo quisiera preguntar siempre se lo
pregunto la gente que conozco para
romper un poco el hielo quienes aquí
creen que yo pueda amarrar me de las
trenzas generalmente la gente dice no yo
no creo que puedas debes pedir ayuda
pedí ayuda vez
aquí está
era
yo hoy en día no sé en qué momento
aprendíamos a romper las trenzas de
nuevo solo sé que fui intentándolo y
cuando grabé ese vídeo y lo vi creo que
fue primera vez que entré en conciencia
de lo complicado que era hacerlo
a dónde nos puede llegar nuestra
curiosidad a mí particularmente me llevo
a cambiar mi vida de una manera positiva
muy positiva a pesar de que la gente lo
que la gente pueda pensar a pesar de que
lo porque lo que pueda aparentar y es
que hace 13 años el 22 de agosto de 2005
yo tuve un accidente más que un
accidente yo creo que fue algo de la
vida saben salir
yo siento que estaba destinado para mí
yo me encontraba en el taller de mi mamá
y había una máquina en medio de
aproximadamente 25 personas y todos
estaban ocupados haciendo lo suyo y yo
por alguna razón curioso niño curioso
voy a la máquina
meto la mano la máquina me traiga el
brazo como pude me esa fe y bueno
entramos en pánico todos mi tío se quita
la camisa me envuelve la mano y corremos
a la clínica que estaba muy cerca como
hacéis calles y
todo fue muy rápido y está en shock sin
embargo como a 50 metros de la clínica
que estaba muy cerca
yo iba sosteniendo mi mano envuelta en
la camisa y yo intento mover los dedos
no sé de se me ocurrió eso
los juegos que se mueven solamente son
mi dedo meñique que aquí lo tengo parte
de medio anular y lo demás no se mueve y
en eso lo que lo primero que yo pienso
entre todo el caos muy adentro mi
subconsciente extraño piensa como tú si
la pones
así luego eso bueno llevo a la clínica y
me hacen una cura y no estaban
capacitadas para aprenderme de manera
correcta así que nos dijeron la tienen
que ir a otra clínica tienen que ir a
otro sitio y así hicimos llegamos a otra
clínica y entre varias cosas que
ocurrieron en el especialista está
ocupado problemas con el seguro yo
acababa de comerme un plato de pasta de
este tamaño y eso afectaba la anestesia
y bueno me atendieron como las 5 horas
este es ayudó a que bueno
me atienden y yo lo que recuerdo es que
desperté al otro día porque la operación
fue muy extensa me quitaron venas y
tendones de este brazo un injerto de
piel de la espalda fue una presión
gigantesca y yo el experto de otro día
rodeado de mi familia
y bueno yo estaba tranquilo me dolió un
poco estaba inmovilizado porque estaba
tranquilo porque estaba toda mi familia
son una familia muy grande y yo me
sentía como de cumpleaños
en estas hacer con una tía que ya fue
enfermera toda su vida era como la
designada para tratar conmigo el tema
delicado y me dice papi este los médicos
intentaron salvar tus dedos sin embargo
estaba un poco infectado y en eso lo
interrumpo y le digo sí tía yo sé que me
tuvieron que amputar lo de tranquila y
entonces
en ese momento llega desde que yo me
desde que yo pensé ya mozilla pone yo
toma esta actitud de que todo va a salir
bien por alguna razón algo en mí de
repente influencia de mi abuela de mi
mamá de mi familia toma esta actitud y
así fue durante los próximos 45 días en
la clínica seis operaciones varios
tratamientos yo me sentí como 45 días de
cumpleaños porque estaban todos mis
primos todas mis tías toda esa gente que
tuve cuando es una ocasión especial sabe
y luego empiezo a hacer terapias casi
inmediatamente
y uno de esos días haciendo una de las
tareas con unos legos se me ocurre armar
una prótesis
y después yo pienso y digo oye quiero
una prótesis sería genial no tanto
porque la necesitaba sino por quiero no
sé robótica los de robóticos
y me decido de eso
posteriormente a un año y medio luego me
retira unas barras de titanio que yo
tenía dentro de mi mano y pude empezar a
usarla y la idea se desvaneció un poco
porque ya pude empezar a utilizar más mi
mano aprendíamos ramas las trenzas de
nuevo
luego en el mundo del deporte
dentro y fuera de venezuela conozco a
muchos atletas que tenían sus prótesis
de pierna de mano y vuelve la idea y voy
a mirar
quiero una prótesis decidí contactar
empresas extranjeras para conseguir una
prótesis
y luego redactó unos correos primera
empresa nada sin respuesta
según la empresa tercera empresa igual
sin respuesta y bueno vamos a seguir
intentando porque había más cuarta
empresa hay respuesta pero me dice en
serio mandaron una foto de tu manager
recordó que yo estaba demostrando cuando
yo responden y yo voy a demostrar nada
más tengo que responderles presencia y
les respondí les envié foto de mi mano y
nada no me respondieron más quinta
empresa me piden fotos de mis manos y
les envío y me dice en serio
lamentamos decirte que no podemos
atenderte porque nos realizamos prótesis
para manos parcialmente amputadas como
la mía sólo realizan prótesis para manos
completamente apuntadas
recuerdo que casualmente yo había
conocido una persona que le contaba mi
historia y me decía oye y por qué no te
corta es lo que te queda de la mano
y llevan verano
los médicos le echaron prisión para
salvar eso
luego se acercaba a mi graduación de
bachillerato ya yo quería estudiar
ingeniería y empecé a empezó este
pensamiento en mi cabeza decir oye
quienes diseñan y construyen las
prótesis ingeniero que va a estudiar tú
en el área mecánica bueno vamos a
hacerlo a nosotros pues yo hablando
conmigo mismo entonces decidí construir
mi propia prótesis y así fue primer
semestre segundo semestre preguntando
aquí y allá haciendo diseño un poco sin
sentido pero yo con mi idea en segundo
semestre llegó a un centro de
investigación de biomecánica en la
universidad de carabobo donde
actualmente estoy desarrollando mi
proyecto y ahí ellos me presentan varias
herramientas computacionales que yo
podía utilizar para para diseñar mi
prótesis
luego sigo avanzando y a pesar de que me
encontraba siempre de cada 32 personas
eran de esas que me decían oye pero eso
es muy difícil no lo hagas a esas
empresas que diseñan prótesis
son equipos de ingeniero equipo de
médicos millones de dólares en
financiamiento no lo vas a lograr hacer
y yo decía nada no importa yo quiero
hacer mi prótesis así sea de madera
y luego en el cuarto semestre conozco un
profesor que por primera vez al fin no
me cierra la puerta y me dice no eso es
muy difícil para ti él me dice oye qué
bueno me gusta tu idea investiga sobre
esto y me presenta lo que es el arduino
y básicamente es un una pequeña
computadora que tú puedes programar para
realizar electrónica digital sencilla
y bueno conociera tú y no tres libros
muchos vídeos compré mi arduino y unos
meses después hice este vídeo
un cuchillo de plástico
unos motores y un ordino
actualmente el diseño luce de esta
manera
fue avanzando a partir de ese semestre
cada vez iba aprendiendo más todo lo
necesario para que avanzara hasta donde
estaba actualmente y de verdad que me
empecé a dar cuenta de que esas personas
que te dicen que no puedes que te dicen
que no deberían hacerlo o esas
situaciones que te hacen sentir que no
deberías seguir que no deberías seguir
intentándolo que es muy difícil
son claves en tu camino para motivarte
para tomarlo como una razón para seguir
a veces esos obstáculos que pueden ser
personas o situaciones son necesarios
porque te obligan a desviar te a ir por
otro camino si hubiese conseguido mi
prótesis hace 67 años cuando las estaba
pidiendo a esas empresas
no sé actualmente no creo que estaría
diseñando mi propia prótesis porque ya
hubiese solucionado esa situación y yo
agradezco que eso me llevó a diseñar mi
prótesis esos profesores que me dijeron
mira esto es muy difícil para ti ellos
me llevaron a decir como que como que
muy difícil de aprender porque si es tan
difícil y no no era tan difícil sólo
había que ponerle corazón al asunto
actualmente estoy construyendo un
prototipo que se los voy a mostrar
hablando de obstáculos este se lo lleva
gracias se los iba a mostrar funcional
con un arduino y van a ver cómo se movía
todo robótico calidad pero casualmente
hace unos instantes antes de la
exposición los vinos se quemó
si en serio se quemó un hombre se había
quemado en los cinco años que lo tengan
y dije bueno estas cosas pasan
vamos a comunicar eso también ue porque
así llegamos el mensaje sin embargo aquí
viene el motor
no está funcionando no tiene
alimentación si algo puede en el
funcionamiento del dedo
uy uy uy
eso es mover un motor que tiene 50
minutos de fuerza que son 5 kilogramos y
los cálculos arrojan que con la prótesis
será capaz ser capaz de sostener
un objeto de un kilogramo con los tres
dedos que me faltan que tiene la
prótesis con estos dos dedos y el pulgar
seré capaz de sostener un objeto de un
kilogramo entre otras cosas
desde un punto de vista técnico
yo me guía para diseñar mi prótesis en
prótesis de alta gama prótesis altamente
competitivas y
actualmente me prótesis compite con esos
modelos en costos sobre todo llegando a
los mismos resultados que ellas entonces
finalmente quiero decirles que
si tienen un sueño si tienen una meta
por más loca grande pequeña que sea a
todos todos esos obstáculos que les
lleguen todas esas personas todas esas
situaciones no las ignoren esas son
valiosas a veces son hasta más valiosas
que las oportunidades porque mucha gente
no ve que es un obstáculo lo podemos
transformar en oportunidades para
evolucionar para crecer y para buscar
otra salida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]